digital leaders prize the ability to
move quickly to seize new opportunities
speed agility of / mount inside this
sort of unprecedented change in a
business climate it's also critical that
businesses bring the expert teams at the
edge of the business what that means is
folks like subject matter experts and
others that operate the business are
involved and their expertise is captured
in every business transaction and every
business interaction for example an
insurance company that we're working
with has thousands of rules what they do
is they use these policies and business
rules to change the packaging and
pricing to the way they present their
services to the client in fact they've
moved from being able to change those
policies once a quarter to once a week
and that's differentiating we're now
steaming at a significant moment in time
based on the ability of cloud to take
these capabilities and not only provide
them and make them available to large
companies but also for mid-sized
enterprises all the way down to
companies of one there are three
attributes that make our operational
decision has been on cloud special the
first is simplicity
the second is speed and the third is
scale from a simplicity standpoint we
have a very powerful user interface
that's aimed at the business that enable
them to very quickly get going it
enables them to focus on the things they
do best which is provide that business
logic in the form of policies to operate
the business
from a speed standpoint it is all about
being able to focus on creating that
content because we did IBM energy IT
operations of that system for you scale
is not just about being able to run 10
mm of rules across dozens of
applications it is also about being able
to enable the business users across the
business to be able to participate in
the Oscar mean the deployment and the
management of those rules that add
agility to your business in a way that
allows you to capture new opportunities
our IBM operational decision manager on
cloud not only has a powerful and
unparalleled business user experience
but it also does something that no one
else in the planet does and that's
provides governance and change
management around your ability to create
and scale business decisions I think
we'll look back at the launch of our
operational decision management on cloud
platform as a time that was significant
in decision technology it's significant
because it's no longer well kept secret
for large enterprises it's now a
business rule system for everyone
[Music]